>>Katlyn: Remember, you are working
on your symbolism reflection piece
that is going on our final website.
Help each other out,
collaborate as you always do.
>>My name is Katlyn
Wolfgang and I teach art
at Central York High School.
I always wanted to become a teacher.
I looked into being a
math teacher and I looked
into being an art teacher.
Art just happens to be the
media in which I teach.
I teach through the arts.
I teach the whole student.
I want the students to
be aware of everything,
of everything around them.
>>Miss Wolfgang is a really great art
teacher because she incorporates more
than just art into the class.
We use social studies, history,
English, writing, reading,
and we also use a lotta
technology, where we're putting all
of our projects and our reflections
onto a website that can be viewed
by anyone that wants to look at it.
>>Ryan: The school identifies and
defines integrated studies really
as curricular connections that
can be made between the subjects
and the different departments
within our high school here.
If you can show students
relevance within the work
that they're doing,
they're more engaged.
They're more apt to be more
interested, to participate more,
and integrated studies is
a great way to do that.
>>That leads us to
number seven where,
can any of you seriously say the Bill
of Rights could get
through Congress today?
>>My name is Dayna Laur
and I teach social studies
at Central York High School.
I don't think any subject matter
is really a stand alone subject.
You know, I think teachers
inherently start
to integrate other subject matters
without maybe really
even thinking about it.
In this particular instance,
though, it's something
that you wouldn't normally see.
An AP class, let alone a politics
class, partnering with an art class.
>>The sculpture class has
had a few questions based
on the information that
you've put on here.
>>Dayna and I were talking and
we decided that we wanted to try
to have a collaborative
piece working.
>>Dayna: My AP government students
are currently researching public
policy issues, looking at why
laws are made, what issues arise
that cause these laws to be created.
And so we have partnered with
Katlyn Wolfgang's class to use art
and sculpture as a forum for
these ideas to be expressed.
>>Katlyn: We tried to decide our goal
and the goal was for her students
to research policy, and my
goal was for my students
to develop a political art piece.
>>Dayna: So the process that you saw
in the classroom today was actually
the students looking at some feedback
that they were given by the
sculpture students on the topics
that they researched,
and additionally,
the sculpture students had
presented us with information
and brainstormed ideas
that they would
like to potentially create
their wire armatures.
>>Katlyn: You have to come
up with these creative ideas
and creative solutions and that's
what the students are forced
to do in my class.
They're forced to take these concepts
and then they have to apply it
to the different medium
that I supply to them.
>>It really is opening the eyes,
I believe, of my AP students,
many of which have never taken an
art class, and really exposing them
to a different medium, as
well as one that can connect
with many more people
in the outside world.
>>As far as working with other
students and collaborating outside
of the classroom, it really
allows you to pull in more ideas
than just the people that
are in your classroom
and learning about the topic.
So we're learning more about
art and they're learning more
about the different ideas that
are going on in AP government.
>>Katlyn: When my students
leave my classroom,
I want them to leave prepared
to embark on the outside world.
>>I want them to have experiences
that are gonna help them elsewhere.
>>If we operate in our classroom
alone and we don't expose ourselves
to ideas of others, or open ourselves
to potential collaboration
opportunities,
then we're not truly going
to serve our students
in that twenty first
century capacity.
In order to open yourself to new
ideas, it really just takes turning
to your colleague next to you.
There are professionals out
there that are more than willing
to get involved in projects that you
may want to do within your classroom.